>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
>> Good Evening.
>> Anne McLean: I'm Anne McLean,
from the library's Music Division.
Thank you so much for coming.
This is a great audience.
We're very pleased tonight to
present a lecture by Marie Rolf.
Debussy's Fascination With the
Exotic: From China to Spain.
Dr. Rolf is Senior Associate Dean
of Graduate Studies and Professor
of Music Theory at the
Eastman School of Music.
As a scholar, her research interests
and publications range from analysis
and performance to the pedagogy
of music theory, and the music
and manuscripts of
Debussy and Mozart.
Throughout her career,
Dr. Rolf has been noted
for her scholarly examinations
of the music of Claude Debussy,
through his exploration -- through
her explorations of his manuscripts,
beginning as early as her
graduate studies at Eastman.
Here at the Library of
Congress, I'm very glad to say
that she has studied a
number of our sources,
and she'll be talking
about that tonight.
She's the editor of the critical
edition of Debussy's "La Mer,"
and has also published
his "Seguidilla"
with the composer's
publisher, Durand.
Currently, she is editing
a volume of his early songs
to be included in his
complete works.
At the Eastman School, in her work
as dean, Dr. Rolf has initiated
and developed a number of new
diploma and certificate programs.
Among these are orchestral studies,
ethnomusicology, and sacred music.
It's really a pleasure to
have her here as a lecturer
under the auspices of the
library's Music Division.
Please welcome Dr. Marie Rolf.
[ Applause ]
>> Marie Rolf: Well, thank you.
And thank you all for being here.
I'm grateful to the Library of
Congress for your kind invitation
for me to speak about one of my very
favorite composers, Claude Debussy,
and specifically, about two
songs-one of the manuscripts
of which is on the table to
my right, and the other is
in a microfilm here at
the Library of Congress.
It is my hope that
during the next hour,
you'll come to share my excitement
and enthusiasm in discovering
and hearing these largely unknown
works by this marvelous composer.
So here we go.
Debussy's Fascination With the
Exotic: From China to Spain.
Throughout his life, Claude
Debussy was captivated by exoticism.
Which essentially involves the
notion of a fascinating other-world.
That is tantalizingly different
from one's native culture.
Some of Debussy's best-loved
compositions, works like "Pagodes"
from his "Estampes" for piano,
and "Ibéria" from the orchestral
"Images" conjure up
landscapes of faraway places,
from the Orient to Spain.
As a cosmopolitan and
relatively well traveled Parisian,
he was exposed to the
traditions, sights,
and sounds of other cultures.
In addition, many of Debussy's
closest friends opened his eyes
vicariously to the art and aesthetic
values of other civilizations.
Among them were: Edmond
Bailly, whose bookshop,
the Librairie de l'Art Independent,
was a hotbed for Orientalism
and esotericism; Pierre
Louÿs and Paul-Jean Toulet,
whose extravagant travels ranged
from Egypt and Algeria, to Tonkin;
and Louis Laloy and Victor
Segalen, whose work took them
to the Far East; and as
Edward Said has reminded us,
Paris was "the capital
of the Orientalist world"
by the turn-of-the-century,
when Debussy was in his prime.
In my presentation today, I aim
to demonstrate how Debussy
absorbed those influences,
and perhaps most importantly
how they served as a catalyst
in the process of his
own compositional growth.
To that end, I will highlight
two of his songs in particular:
the "Rondel Chiniois"
and "Séguidille,"
treasures whose manuscripts are
preserved in the Music Division,
here at the Library of Congress
and that were never published
during Debussy's lifetime.
In fact, the "Rondel Chinois"
finally appeared only in 2013.
Edited privately by Nigel Foster,
for the London Song Festival,
and "Séguidille" was released by
Durand-Debussy's own publisher,
in a score edited by yours
truly in August 2014.
The manuscript of the "Rondel
Chinois" has been housed
at the Library of Congress
since 1930 when it was purchased
from Henry Pennier, by Carl
Engel, and the manuscript
of "Séguidille" is currently
in a private collection.
Whose owner has graciously
shared a microfilm
of it with the Music Division.
Debussy was still a teenager when
he composed the "Rondel Chinois."
While he had not yet had personal
encounters with Eastern music,
he could not have escaped the craze
in Paris during his formative
years, for art of the Orient.
Following the opening of trade
channels between the East
and West in the mid-19th century.
The European market was flooded
with articles such as prints,
ceramics, furniture, ivories.
Silk and bronze works
from China and Japan.
Dealers like Siegfried Bing began
to import Orientalist
objects in the 1870s.
From 1888 until '91, he
published a monthly journal called
"Le Japon Artistique," and by
1895 he opened a shop called l'Art
Nouveau in the 9th arrondissement.
If you look over the doorway there
you can see the words l'Art Nouveau.
This is slightly later architecture,
but an example of architecture
from the 1860's, that was conceived
in Oriental style is
the Bataclan Theater.
Originally a cafe-concert,
but which has been
in the news this past weekend as
you know, for very sad reasons,
as the site of a devastating
terrorist attack.
And the black-and-white photo on the
left is a photo from around 1900.
The theater opened in 1865, but it
still has its original pagoda roof
and is very Orientalist-style.
And the color photo on the
bottom right is from 2008,
when it has just recently
been-had recently been painted.
Other individuals, like Enrico
Cernuschi, a patriot who fled Italy
after the 1848 revolution
and relocated to Paris,
where he would become
a wealthy banker,
collected Oriental art
on a massive scale.
Disheartened by the Paris
commune of 1871, Cernuschi decided
to escape the turmoil in his
adoptive city and traveled
around the world from 1871
to '73, during which time,
he purchased approximately
5,000 artworks.
Many of them Chinese bronzes.
Upon returning to Paris, he
displayed them at the Palace
of Industry, contributing to the
emergence of a Japonisme in France.
Today, one can still view
his fabulous art collection
at his former home, now the Musée
Cernuschi in the Parc Monceau.
Artists in Europe embraced
exotic elements from the East,
celebrating its linear qualities
and lavish colors in their canvases.
As early as 1875, Claude
Monet memorialized his wife
in kimono dress in this
flamboyant painting now preserved
at the Museum of Fine
Arts in Boston.
There she is.
In 1886-7, Vincent
van Gogh portrayed
"Le Père Tanguy" three times,
the third of which most
unabashedly reflects Orientalism.
That same year, van Gogh quite
literally copied two prints
by the great Japanese
Ukiyo-e artist, Hiroshige.
The first is the Flowering Plum
Tree"-that's Hiroshige's woodblock
from 1857, and here is
van Gogh's copy from 1887.
Also, Hiroshige's "Bridge In the
Rain"- I love that rain coming
down diagonally, from 1857 and
van Gogh's copy 20 years later.
Even James McNeill Whistler,
so well-known for his monochromatic
portraits and watery nocturnes,
could not resist the
lure of the East.
In 1863, he began painting
"The Princess from the Land
of Porcelain," which eventually was
incorporated into the Peacock Room,
now in the Freer Gallery, here in
Washington, D.C. The Japanese screen
in the background may have
belonged to Whistler himself,
who passionately collected
Oriental objects, including china,
lacquerware, and Japanese
woodblock prints.
And here she is in C2 in
the Peacock Room with many
of those ceramics along the wall.
The contemporary musicians and
writers in France were not immune
to this pervasive influence
of exoticism.
In the decade between 1875, when
Bizet's "Carmen" was premiered
in Paris, and 1885, when Gilbert
and Sullivan's "Mikado" opened
in London, French stage works
were teeming with exotic subjects.
From Delibes' "Lakme" to Massenet's
"Le Roi de Lahore" and " Le Cid."
The Goncourt brothers were
actively chronicling Parisian art
and society, Including
the rage for Orientalism.
They avidly followed
Cernuschi and began themselves
to collect Japanese prints
and Chinese porcelain,
displaying these objects
in their home,
amidst their 18th-century French
treasures, often commenting
on the resonances between the
arts of the East and West.
Later, in the 1890s, Edmond de
Goncourt published on the works
of Hokusai and Utamaro, whom
he called the Watteau of Japan.
It's no wonder that Debussy,
who was coming of age
in this exotically saturated
milieu, was swept up in the current.
He, too, venerated the work
of Hokusai and Utamaro.
As shown in this famous
photograph of the composer
with his guest Igor Stravinsky
taken in his study decades later.
On the wall behind the
composers, at the top,
hangs Hokusai's "Great Wave off
Kanagawa," which Debussy requested
for the cover of the first edition
of his orchestral masterpiece
"La Mer."
Hokusai is on the left, cover
of "La Mer" on the right,
and beneath it is Utamaro's portrait
of Wakatsuru as she reads a letter,
echoing the second scene in Act
I of "Pelléas et Mélisande,"
where Genevieve reads
Golaud's letter aloud
to the blind King Arkel.
On Debussy's desk is his beloved and
ever present wooden toad from Japan,
a fetish that the composer
named Arkel,
who brought him good
luck on his travels.
There is a grande dame
in Debussy research
who is now deceased-her name
was Margaret Cobb-who used
to tell the story about
Debussy traveling.
And he would say.
[ Foreign Language ]
"Don't put Arkel in the suitcase.
He doesn't like that [laughter]."
Debussy, an inveterate smoker,
also owned this Japanese
lacquered cigarette case
and this 19th century
lacquer work of gold fish,
encrusted with mother-of-pearl.
These poisons d'or inspired one
of his "Images" for piano in 1907.
Even when he could ill afford
such objets d'art during his student
years, Debussy coveted curios
and was known to have spent
time and money acquiring them.
It is thus perhaps no surprise, that
he would be attracted to the sensual
"Rondel Chinois," a poem which
paints a Chinese tableau.
This is a tableau by Hokusai
set on a lake that is bordered
with azaleas, water
lilies, and bamboo.
On the water, floats a mahogany junk
boat, in which a lady sleeps veiled
in a swath of crepe up to her
neck, while a Mandarin observes her
with his owl-like eyes from his
lazy veranda in the distance.
The author of this captivating
landscape was unknown
until a few years ago when Debussy
scholar Denis Erlin [phonetic] was
able to identify the
poet as Marius Dillard.
A critic of literature,
art, and music,
Dillard eventually
became the director
of a magazine called Rouen-Artiste.
While yet in his teens, he had
won a poetry contest with his
"Rondel Chinois," and as
a result, it was published
in the May 5, 1878 issue of the --
"Union littéraire des
poètes et des prosateur"
Debussy, two years younger than
Dillard, chose to set the text
of the "Rondel Chinois" as a
song for Madame Marie Vasnier,
a coloratura soprano, whom
he accompanied as a student
and who would inspire no fewer
than 29 of his early Melodies.
Young Achille, which
was his given name,
was besotted by this
married older woman,
and she in turn must've been
flattered by his attention.
Before long, they became
deeply involved.
The flowery dedications to Madame
Vasnier that Achille penned
on his manuscripts bear witness to
the intimacy of their relationship.
The manuscript of the "Rondel
Chinois" is no exception.
You can see the original
on the table.
I'm sorry, the copy is not
terribly legible, but if you look
in the top left corner, he
writes: "To Madame Vasnier.
The only person who can sing
and make forgettable
all that this music has.
That is un-singable and perplexing."
He says:
[ Foreign Language ]
In French, the phrase [foreign
words] is the equivalent
of "it's Greek to me" in English.
So in this dedication the
composer is cleverly punning
on the adjective "chinois."
Following the title of the
song, the composer continues
with tongue-in-cheek,
identifying the work
of the last two lines
on this slide, as --
[ Foreign Language ]
"Chinese music based on
manuscripts of the period,"
which was, of course, bogus.
It's clear, even from
this title page,
that this piece was a calculated
attempt to render the allure
of the unconventional,
or exotic, in sound.
Although this autographed
manuscript is not dated.
We can infer a date of
1881 for two reasons.
First, young Achille misspelled
Marie's last name-you'll be able
to see it on the table there-as V,
A, N, I, E, R. Instead of V, A, S,
N, I, E, R. It's only by
January 1882 that he began
to spell Marie's name correctly on
manuscripts, so we know this has
to be prior to that time.
Second, Debussy biographers report
that he accompanied
Marie in a recital.
Which included the
"Rondel Chinois" in 1881.
While unfortunately no program
of that event has been preserved,
we do have a printed program
for a recital in which Marie
and Achille performed
two of his other songs,
"Fete Galante" and "Le Roses."
They're down four from the
bottom, there on 12 May, 1882.
And if you look at the
top, about the third line
down you will see he
must have discovered how
to spell her name correctly by this
time, since it was printed as V, A,
S, N, I, E, R on the program.
Dillard' poem is a classic
Rondel form, in that it consists
of 13 lines, two quatrains,
followed by a quintal,
With a two line refrain that
opens the first quatrain
and closes the second.
In his "Rondel Chinois," only the
first line of the refrain returns
after the final quintal and
the challenge for the poet is
to find seven compelling
rhymes for the A-lines
and six rhymes for the B-lines.
Ideally, the poet will also
illuminate a new aspect
of the original idea each time.
Rather than simply repeating
the refrain for its own sake.
In the "Rondel Chinois," Dillard
continually shifts the focus
of his images, not
unlike a videographer.
In the first strophe, he moves
from the general landscape
on the lake bordered with azaleas,
water lilies, and with bamboo,
to focus on the slight motion
of the boat within that scene.
A mahogany junk with a
gold tapered bow passes by.
But in the second strophe,
Dillard reverses orientation,
training his lens first on
detail, the sleeping Chinese woman
who is clothed in crepe, and then
executing a literary focus poll,
by situating her within the
wide-angle landscape of the lake.
In the following quintal,
he transfers our attention
from the crepe dress of the
woman in the boat on the water
to the lacey veranda of
the Mandarin on the shore
who is watching with owl-like eyes.
Who? The Chinese woman
who is passing by.
Where? On the Lake
bordered with azaleas.
So you see that Debussy's
continually shifting --
Dillard's continually
shifting juxtaposition
of images creates a sense of
fluidity and panoramic vision,
in spite of the repeated refrains.
Each line of a Rondel typically
contains eight syllables.
And Dillard's poem follows
this principle as well.
[ Foreign Language ]
There's eight.
While Debussy does not
repeat musical material,
for each of the refrains of the
"Rondel" circled in this slide,
he does respond to its three large
divisions by casting his song
in a ternary form -- ABA.
Both of the A sections convey
the pastoral scene in the tonic
or home key of A-minor, while
the B material centers closely --
centered on the closely related key
of C-major and features a new motive
and increased rhythmic
motion in the piano.
Debussy echoes Dillard's
octosyllabic lines in his choice
of a duple meter and a regular
two and four bar phrase structure.
In the A section, the
piano conveys the sensation
of a boat gliding gently
on the water.
The language, duple pulse,
emphasized by hollow open fifth
petals in the bass on the downbeats,
contrast with dissonances on
the second part of each measure,
simulating a steady ebb
and flow of the water.
Against this placid
backdrop, as you just heard,
Debussy lavishes ornamental
interest in the vocal line,
which is clearly designed to
suggest a mysterious other-a foreign
fragrance of the East.
This melody is replete with
pentatonic inflections,
a non-Western pitch
organization, that are overlaid
on a similarly exotic
modal quasi-Dorian canvas.
Whether the voice is that of
the lady in the boat or that
of a narrator, we hear her before we
meet her, as Debussy opens his song
with a captivating vocalise.
Of course, in a practical sense,
passages such as this were composed
to show off Madame Vasnier's
high and agile voice.
In Debussy's "Rondel Chinois,"
they also serve a structural
function introducing the A section
and, as well as, the
re-transition to the final A,
and then ending the song.
Let's now hear at least the A and
B sections of this entire song,
performed by Natalie
Dessay and Philippe Cassard.
I will -- I'll perhaps
over-dub where we are,
because they are very
metrically free here.
It may be hard for you to
follow the phraseology.
And then a return of A. Just as van
Gogh was copying Hiroshige's "Bridge
In the Rain," so was Debussy
imitating what he knew
of Chinese musical conventions in
his setting of the "Rondel Chinois."
Our knowledge of his precise musical
models is scant, but presumably,
he would've been copying Western
imitations of Eastern music
at this time in his life,
because his first serious exposure
to indigenous music of the East
would not occur until later in 1889
at the Paris World's Fair.
And, just as van Gogh would absorb
elements of Japanese Ukiyo-e
into his own artworks, so
too did Debussy harness some
of the musical ideas that he
had developed in imitation
of Eastern musics and
incorporate them
into his own distinctly
French works.
A clear illustration of
this assimilation is found
in his song entitled "Fête
Galantes," based on a poem
by Theodore de Banville
and composed just one year
after the "Rondel Chinois."
There is no hint of
Orientalism in Banville's poem.
Rather, it evokes the very French
genre of the "Fête Galantes,"
depicting elegantly dressed men and
women, often in a park-like setting,
and engaging in amorous
play a la Watteau.
This is his famous...
[ Foreign Language ]
Debussy would soon turn
to Verlaine's collection
of " Fête Galantes," setting
eight of the 22 poems to music,
but in a sense, he
apprenticed in the genre
by setting Banville's poem first.
In Debussy's "Fete Galantes" song,
which the composer himself described
as Louis XIV music with
formulae from 1882,
he re-appropriated
melodic embellishments
from the "Rondel Chinois."
Already in the opening
gesture he composed a melody
with the same characteristic turns,
outlining the open fifth in blue
and emphasizing the flat three
and flat six scale degrees in red
and green, and the primary
difference being that the
" Fête Galantes " tune
is now in triple meter.
You see the 3-4 there, instead
of the duple meter of
the "Rondel Chinois."
The second phrase in both
songs moves up to the high A
and exhibits the same
Dorian inflected F-sharp
within the melisma.
I've adjusted the spacing in
the notation of this example
to juxtapose visually
the similar outlines
and have bracketed parallel
pitch material in the same color,
but you'll be able to
hear this immediately.
Debussy's approach to the final
cadence shows further resonances
between the two songs, ending
with an extended vocalise
that ascends stepwise to the high
A. Possessed with perfect pitch,
the composer would
surely have been conscious
of these direct melodic connections.
Likewise, his tonal plan,
though more complex in the later
"Fête Galantes" song, shows a
similar opening move from the tonic
of A-minor to C and the
phraseology remains very square.
Because he's no longer
attempting to evoke the Orient,
Debussy limits his use of
pentatonicism and a drone bass
in the "Fête Galantes,"
but he maintains the
melismatic pitch material
that he developed in
the "Rondel Chinois."
Even at the same pitch
level as we have seen
and he retains the modal
inflections and the vocalises,
as well, beginning and end.
In an even more extreme
act of self-borrowing,
he eventually recycled and
refashioned the material from his
"Fête Galantes" song
into the minuet movement
of his petite suite
for piano four hands.
So here's the opening of the
song, as sung by Anne-Marie Rodde
and played on piano, the --
performed by the late
and great Noel Lee.
Compare that to Noel Lee and
Werner Haas playing the beginning
of the minuet from
the "Petite Suite."
The point is, the distinctive pitch
elements and melodic treatment
that emanated from his engagement
with an oriental subject
were eventually assimilated
into his own uniquely French
compositional vocabulary.
Of course, the East was not
the only source of foreign
and exotic influence for Debussy
or other artists of his time.
Keenly aware of his environment,
he could not fail to
have been influenced.
As were Bizet, Chabrier,
and later, Ravel,
by France's well establish
attraction to all things Spanish.
Debussy was too young to enjoy
the Spanish gallery established
at the Louvre from 1838
to '48 by collectors,
or perhaps one should more
aptly call them plunderers.
Such as Marshal Soult, who arrived
in Spain during the Napoleonic
occupation of 1808 to '14
and brought back many
treasures to Paris.
However, a recently
discovered letter suggests
that Debussy may have had
the opportunity to view some
of the Velasquez paintings
at the Prado in Madrid prior
to his residency at
the Villa Medici,
as a winner of the Prix de Rome.
And he surely would have been
exposed to Spanish folk songs
and dancing performed in the
cafes and on the streets of Paris.
Among his very first
compositions was "Madrid,"
drawn from Alfred de Musset's
"Contes d'Espagne et d'Italie."
In it, Musset portrays a
seductive Andalusian temptress,
not unlike "Carmen"
in Bizet's opera.
Debussy presumably attended
a performance of "Carmen"
in Vienna, in November 1882.
With his patroness
Madame Nadezhda von Meck,
who two years earlier was said to
have treated him to a bullfight
in San Sebastián while he
was staying with her family
in Arcachon in southwestern France.
As Tchaikovsky's devoted
patroness, Madame von Meck was eager
to introduce the young Debussy
to the Russian composer's music
and she asked him to
transcribe, among other things,
the "Danse Espagnole" from "Swan
Lake" for piano four hands.
Back in Paris at the
Conservatoire, it's highly likely
that Debussy would have
come to know Carmen well
through his composition
teacher Ernest Guiraud,
who constructed the
recitatives for Bizet's opera
and compiled 12 numbers from it
into two orchestral
suites in 1882 and 1887.
Other Spanish influences on
Debussy may have come from faculty
and students at the Conservatoire,
for instance, his harmony teacher,
Emile Durand, had set Théophile
Gautier's "Séguidille" already
in 1874, which may have prompted
Debussy to try his own hand at it.
As is the case for
the "Rondel Chinois,"
there is only one complete
manuscript source
for Debussy's "Séguidille."
Although it is not
dated we can surmise,
based on the paper type used,
the layout of the manuscript,
and other chirographic evidence,
that it was completed sometime
after the end of March 1883,
the year following his
composition of "Fête Galantes."
And the cover page for "Séguidille"
features the song's title
in the center creatively lettered,
diagonally down to the
right and followed by --
[ Foreign Language ]
...with, of course, the
dedication on the top right
of the page, to Madame Vasnier.
Debussy's signature on
the last page of this
"Séguidille" score is quite similar
to his signature for "Invocation"
from May 1883, as well as
that on the flyleaf of the
"Recueil Vasnier," a collection
of 13 songs which Debussy finished
by February '84 and
which he presented
to Marie Vasnier sometime
before leaving for Rome.
The most intriguing clue in
our quest to ascribe a date
of composition for "Séguidille"
comes from a phantom page
in the "Recueil Vasnier."
It follows the sixth song in the
collection, "Coquetterie Posthume,"
which was also based on a Gautier
text and dated at the bottom there.
It's very hard to see but
it's 31 Mars-March, '83.
The folio after the end of the
"Coquetterie Posthume" song
was mysteriously excised
from the volume.
However, ink blots bled from
the folio that was removed
onto the remaining page and if one
reverses the image of the inkblots,
reading backwards,
from right to left,
the outlines of the
accompanimental figuration,
as well as the descending
arabesque-like triplets
of the vocal line of
"Séguidille," are clearly exposed.
Maybe not so clear on these slides.
Not even that clear, in reality.
You need a [inaudible]
-- what do you call that.
Thank you.
To see it well.
Including the folio
that was excised,
11 consecutive pages were left
blank in the "Recueil Vasnier,"
approximately the number
needed for a title page
and the planned notation of the
entire song of "Séguidille."
So clearly, Debussy
was already working
on "Séguidille" during
the first half of 1883
after the "Coquettesie Posthume."
The female character in Gautier's
poem is decidedly different
from the elegant Chinese woman
in Dillard's "Rondel Chinois."
Having spent a great deal of time
in Spain, Gautier was seeking
to portray a Manola, a
characteristically bohemian
and flirtatious woman
of strong temperament,
and in flamboyant dress.
In his book, "Voyage on Espagne,"
he wrote of his exhaustive search
for a pure-blooded
Manola while in Spain
and we might imagine her is
similar to the earthy depiction
of Francisco de Goya's
"Una Manola," shown here.
Or, perhaps more like the seductive
dancer in John Singer Sargent's
"El Jaleo," painted in 1882 just
right in the same time period.
That, you can see at the Isabella
Stewart Gardner Museum in Boston.
In any case, the Manola in
"Séguidille" wears a tight skirt
and huge comb in her chignon.
Her gestures are bold and carefree
with no thought for the morrow.
And she sings and dances
to the sound of castanets,
dallying with the toreadors
while smoking cigarettes.
The structure of Gautier's poem
follows the general outline
of a traditional poetic seguidilla,
which consists of a four-line copla
or quatrain, followed by a
three estribillo, or tercet,
that serves as a refrain.
In classic seguidillas, each
Copla alternates lines of seven
and five syllables with
a rhyme scheme of ABAB,
and each estribillo reverses
the pattern with lines
of 5-7-5 syllables and
a rhyme scheme of CDC.
Furthermore, all of the five
syllable lines typically
feature assonance.
While these details vary somewhat
in Gautier's "Séguidille,"
the basic structure
remains and he concludes
with the estribillo refrain that
celebrates the lively Manola.
"Alza! Olá!
La veritable Manola."
Debussy celebrated her as
well, up to a high C-sharp.
Not only does the song exude
the Manola's overt flamboyance,
but its abrupt conclusion
reflects the bien parado
of a typical seguidilla dance,
in which the performers freeze
in their final position.
As you can see in the next slide
Debussy's form -- musical form --
parallels Gautier 's
poetic structure.
His extended 46-bar introduction,
featuring the Manola's vocalise,
is followed by strophe one,
or Copla one in A-minor,
w ith its virtuosic refrain,
the estribillo, in tonic major.
Strophe two is cast in the
relative major of C. These --
do you remember these keys?
And a coloratura cadenza leads to
the return of A for strophe three,
which ends with a bien parado on
a high C-sharp in tonic major.
This formal and tonal plan, as
well as the prominent vocalises,
were all seen in the "Rondel
Chinois" from two years earlier.
However, just as Debussy captured
the flavor of Eastern musics in his
"Rondel Chinois," so did he openly
adopt Spanish musical formulate
in "Séguidille."
In fact, many of the
musical clichés
in his song closely
resemble conventions found
in the most popular Spanish
spectacle of the day,
none other than Bizet's "Carmen."
I could focus an entire lecture on
the parallels between Bizet's opera
and Debussy's song, but will
limit myself to just a few
of their characteristic features.
One of the most obvious, is the
similarly abrupt and dramatic ending
of "Carmen's" own "Séguidille,"
from act one of the opera.
You all know this.
This is thanks to Marilyn
Horne that we're hearing it.
Indeed, Debussy picked up on
numerous other Spanish formula
from Bizet's "Séguidille," many
of which are also present in his
"Habanera" and "Chanson Bohème."
However, Debussy's song echoes
perhaps most persuasively,
the "Entr'acte" linking acts
three and four of "Carmen."
Both works feature a quick triple
meter, slow harmonic rhythm,
and chromatic inflections
especially on flat six and flat two.
This is the opening
of the "Entr'acte".
Above this foundation, Bizet
introduces a descending line related
to "Carmen's" earlier "Habañera."
[ Singing ]
You know, that descending line-but
now more languid and syncopated,
and then contrast it with
a florid ascending melody.
Ultimately, this passage gives
way to trills and scalar runs.
Debussy's song features
similar runs in the cadenza,
after the middle B section.
And "Carmen's" triplet-inflected
melody becomes even more
death-defying in Debussy's score.
As well, at the climax
of the "Entr'acte,"
Bizet exposes a descending
tetrachord in the base.
Sometimes called an Andalusian,
or Spanish tetrachord.
Again, Debussy exploits
this cliché fully
in his setting of "Séguidille."
However, Debussy's
opening tetrachord descends
to a tri-tone away.
You see the circled red
notes, E, D, C, B to B-flat,
which ultimately functions as a
phyrigian flat two in A-minor.
Above this surprising twist of the
base, to B-flat, the voice enters
on E, he tri-tone above
with a flamboyant trill,
and continues with that descending
syncopated line that's uncannily
reminiscent of the tune
in Bizet's "Entr'acte."
Finally, Bizet is fond of
overlapping his melodies
above four bar ostinato
units in the accompaniment.
I've circled the four bar
foundation in blue here.
And shown the melody in red, how
it overlaps those four bar units.
Debussy picks up on this notion of
non-synchronous phrase structure,
already in his vocal
introduction with a five bar phrase
that overlaps the four bar
pattern established in the piano.
Similarly, the opening of the first
Copla contains a five bar vocal
entry over regular four
bar phrases in the piano.
Let's now hear this
marvelous song composed
by the 21-year-old
Achille-Claude Debussy.
I'm going to play the A
section with the refrain.
Let's do the B section,
[foreign language],
and then there's this extended
cadenza instead of the refrain
and I think I'll stop it after that.
Debussy's sequel to "Séguidille"
was a "Chanson Espagnole"
that he substituted in the
"Recueil Vasnier" in place
of his momentarily
aborted "Séguidille."
Ultimately, he codified his
Spanish musical style in the
"Chanson Espagnole," a duet
intended for Marie Vasnier to sing
with her teacher, Madam
Morosanti [phonetic],
and that showcased their virtuosity.
Based on a text by Alfred de Musset,
whose "Madrid" Debussy had set
as a rather unimaginative strophic
song several years earlier,
the "Chanson Espagnole"
had been popularized
by Delibes and others as...
"Les filles de Cadix"
It would become Debussy's
third song about a bullfight,
the story told this time
from the perspective
of the toreador who's flirting
with girls near the bullring.
In the "Chanson Espagnole" Debussy
pulled together the Bolero rhythm
that he had used in "Madrid"
and that Bizet had
used in his "Entr'acte"
[ Singing ]
...with the other Spanish
conventions
that we've already heard: triple
meter, a slow harmonic rhythm,
chromatic and modal inflections,
especially on flat six and flat two,
virtuosic octave leaps, runs
and trills in the voice.
triplet inflected descending
melodic motives,
and a descending Andalusian
tetrachord in the base.
Perhaps most memorably,
he highlighted the dual soprano's
elaborate vocalises at the beginning
of the song and in the refrains,
as you can see the bottom line,
"les filles de Cadix," following
each of the two strophes as he had
in the "Séguidille," and he
finished with an abrupt bien parado,
just as he had concluded
the " Séguidille."
And the piece ends with
the, just the high B...
[ Singing ]
...with the bien parado.
As he matured, Debussy
continued to expand
and refine his Spanish
musical vocabulary,
especially as he intersected with
Spanish composers such as Albeniz,
Manuel de Falla and Enrique
Granados, and the pianist,
Ricardo Viñes, who would
premier the Spanish inspired
"Soirée dans Grenade," from
Debussy's "Estampes" in 1904,
as well as "La Serenade Interrompue"
from the first book
of preludes in 1911.
Debussy's later full
assimilation of Spanish elements
into his own compositional
vocabulary is evident in works
such as "Iberia" and
other piano preludes.
These works reflect his continued
exposure to, and exploration of,
indigenous Spanish folk songs
as they were disseminated
in anthologies published
by individuals
such as Filipe Pedrell and others.
And of course, he absorbed many
other Orientalist sights and sounds
through the Paris World Fairs.
During his formative years as
a composer, in the early 1880s,
Debussy's initial attraction
to Orientalist philosophies
and values may have triggered his
attempts to compose transculturally.
That is, to imitate
and adopt the stylistic
and formal conventions
of another culture.
But ultimately, he absorbed and
generalized these exotic elements
within his own musical
vocabulary, fully integrating them
as he developed his
unique compositional voice.
Perhaps that is why his music is
so universally loved and admired
by people throughout the world.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I think we have time for one or
two questions, if you have any.
>> We have one.
>> Marie Rolf: Okay.
Great.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Marie Rolf: Sir.
>> Firstly, I apologize that I
was late the first few minutes
because of the traffic.
I would like to bring up people's
attention on the painting.
The character is Kenshi,
Chinese characters
indicated Okinawa's landscape.
>> Marie Rolf: Yes.
It is from Kenshi.
It is Hokusai 's, from Kenshi.
There are eight views.
Yes.
>> Okinawa.
>> Marie Rolf: It is.
Yes.
>> However, I would like to bring
up attention that the choice
of the color and the spacing pattern
of the painting could be
more Japanese than Chinese,
but under the influence
of Chinese ink brush.
Thank you.
>> Marie Rolf: Nancy.
>> Could you elaborate more
on the personal relationship
between Debussy and Bizet?
In -- there's so much similarity.
Was it friendly, or
was it competitive
in the way they were interacting?
>> Marie Rolf: No.
Bizet died, in fact when Guiraud --
>> Of course.
Because Bizet died in the same time.
>> Marie Rolf: Yes.
Yes. So Debussy would
have known Bizet mainly
through his composition teacher...
>> Of course.
>> Marie Rolf: ...Ernest Guiraud,
with whom he began to study in 1880.
And it was in '82 that Guiraud
composed the recitatives
for "Carmen," posthumously --
that is, posthumous for Bizet.
But when Bizet died, the
recitatives had not been --
>> Written.
>> Marie Rolf: -- Composed yet.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Marie Rolf: Yep.
Well, I imagine you're all dying to
see the "Rondel Chinois" over there
and look to see the way he
misspelled Madame Vasnier's name.
We have, I believe, the "Nocturnes,"
the orchestral "Nocturnes,"
which are dedicated to
another lady in his life,
Lily who was his first wife.
You'll see the said dedication
is "To my dear Lily, Lilo."
We have the "Rondel Chinois."
We have "Apparition,"
which was based
on a Mallarmé poem he
composed in 1884 just shortly
after these other works
we've been looking at today.
And then, there's some Chausson,
Franck, what else, David?
[ Inaudible ]
>>Marie Rolf: Ravel,
Chansons madécasses
Yes.
>> Thank you so much.
That was wonderful.
But you said earlier [inaudible]?
>> Marie Rolf: Of course,
none of these songs were ever
published during his lifetime
and they are all so high
and so difficult to sing.
They really were written
for Marie --
for Madame Vasnier and once
their relationship was over,
which happened probably 1887.
Monsieur figured out what was going
on, and that was sort of the end.
Debussy came back from Rome and it
was over, but he realized that he --
if he wanted anybody to sing these.
He couldn't write such
high tessitura
and such difficult coloratura.
So -- and that be --
even more importantly.
He became very attracted and
drawn to symbolist literature,
which is very understated and
it's all about implication.
It's not heart on the sleeve.
It's all more inner.
And because of that aesthetic
shift in his thinking.
He would never have
composed a piece like this.
So even after April of 1902,
when "Pelléas" was premiered
and became incredibly popular.
I mean, it just catapulted
him to fame overnight.
The publishers were asking for more
works and he couldn't possibly keep
up with the demand, so he often went
into his old, you know, portfolios
and "what can I resurrect and
slightly tweak and publish?"
But he still chose not to do these.
And I think it was
for aesthetic reasons.
>> Great. Thank you so much.
Unfortunately, we do have
to run out of -- well.
We have a limit on how long
we can be in the building.
So we'd love to get you
over to the manuscripts.
And if you have any further
questions for the speaker,
feel free to see her
privately over there.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.